huge fight
over
Sports
and I guess education and I guess the
whole way our society views itself this
out of my old home Gamora by the Sea Los
Angeles I was just back there to do some
shoots for my prageru book club show and
before I left for California there was a
big hubbub because there's a pro drag
group
that is very anti-christian specifically
anti-catholic but broadly very
sacrilegious it's called The Sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence and this group
exists to mock Christianity mock
religious orders mock our Lord and mock
virtue and and pervert all of it into
sin and make fun of of religious people
okay so they were going to be honored at
Dodger Stadium as part of pride month
festivities in the middle of June and
there was naturally an outcry over this
this was extremely offensive and so then
the LA Dodgers said okay we're not going
to invite this degenerate group to to
the middle of the stadium to honor them
in the middle of June and then there was
an outcry from the pro-lgbt group and so
the Dodgers have come back and they said
okay we're reinviting the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence after much
thoughtful feedback from our diverse
communities honest conversations within
the LA Dodgers organization and generous
discussions with the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence the LA Dodgers
would like to offer a sincerest
apologize to the apologies to the
sisters members of the lgbtq plus
community and their friends and Families
we've asked the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence to take their place on the
field of our 10th Annual lgbtq Pride
night on June 16th we're pleased to
share that they've agreed to receive the
Gratitude of our Collective communities
wait for this for the life-saving work
that they have done tirelessly for
decades
life-saving work so jiggling around for
drunk drug addled weirdos that's
life-saving work mocking Christianity
and engaging in extremely perverse
burlesque and Cabaret acts that is
life-saving work meanwhile you've got
actual Catholic nuns who are literally
saving people's lives taking care of
little babies taking care of the elderly
taking care of the sick they're never
going to get their night at Dodgers
Stadium not going to happen but the the
weird sex troupe that mocks those nuns
they get honored for their life-saving
work
and then you got the Dodgers logo there
in the in the rainbow flag the rainbow
flag which is as far as I'm concerned is
the the most dangerous hate symbol in
the country hear all about all these
hate symbols you know there's this is
these are very offensive symbols we've
got to run away from the hate symbols to
me nothing tells me that you are on the
wrong side of things quite like that
pride flag The Pride Flag represents
pride is the deadliest of the seven
deadly sins and now these Maniacs are
are honoring a group of
anti-catholic anti-religious perverts
now what's the takeaway from this well I
guess the takeaway is that the LA
Dodgers have become Elga Dodgers am I
right but but if if I had to find any
deeper meaning in all of this
the meaning is this
the Dodgers have to pick between actual
religious sisters and
the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
these dudes jailing around making fun of
Christ they have to choose one of those
things
because if they invite this drag troop
they're going to offend the Christians
if they disinvite the drag troop they're
going to offend the sexual
revolutionaries and the libs
they have to pick one and the Dodgers
said okay we're going to offend the
Christians who cares about the
Christians we don't like the Christians
we're so we're going to side with the
sexual revolutionaries and all the libs
in the short term they probably made the
right choice because that is where the
powerful people in our culture are
that's the camp that they reside in
so they say okay we're going to pick the
politically correct one we're going to
pick the side of ESG we're going to pick
the side of the liberal establishment
we're going to pick the side of of the
media and the colleges and all the rest
of it in the long run I think they
picked the wrong side in the let's say
Eternal run I think they definitely
picked the wrong side here
but they do have to pick a side and the
squishes who want to say well we'll just
be neutral about all this you can't be
neutral either the sacrilegious drag
queens get invited to the baseball
stadium the public place the this
Central public place built in part with
taxpayer money for the sports and the
games which always have a patriotic
public role in any society either the
drag queens get invited to the center of
the field or they don't
either the Christians get to set the
Norms or the weirdos get to set the
Norms they there are lots of different
kinds of weirdos but in particular the
lib sexual revolutionary weirdos but
someone's going to set them
somebody is going to set them I would
rather it be the people who are in favor
of the good the true and the Beautiful
but that's not the way the culture is
looking right now
you want to simplify your culture if you
want to simplify your business finances
well you got to check out ramp right now
go to ramp.com Knowles are you looking
for a better way to simplify your
business finances across expenses vendor
payments and accounting if so ramp could
be a complete game changer for your
business ramp is a corporate card and
expense management software designed to
help you save time and money with ram
you can issue cards to every employee
with limits and restrictions and
automate expense reporting so you can
stop wasting time at the end of every
month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to the time he'll save
each month on employee expenses will
allow you to close your books eight
times faster businesses that use Ram
see an average of three and a half
percent within the first year ramp is
easy to use you get started in less than
15 minutes whether you have five
employees or five thousand right now
at 250 when you join ramp go to ramp.com
Knowles kwles cards issued by Sutton
Bank and Celtic Bank members FDIC terms
and conditions apply I came across a
video
of a therapist this is a 15-year veteran
therapist she's been in the job for a
long time she's very clearly a lib
and she
it gave one of the most precise and
insightful definitions of wokeness a
word that has eluded definition in
certain quarters that I have ever heard
it's only really over the past six or
seven months that I've understood
um my racial identity and begun to
really deconstruct it personally and
from within and understanding that in
terms of the psychology of white folks
who are my people I grew up in Seattle
very like liberal whiteness environment
and that is I'm in that environment
still so
um yeah and I work as a therapist I've
been working as a therapist for about 15
years
so I really see this as a um a healing
journey and to me
really the only real spiritual path of
meaning available to my folks so and I
yeah
there it is
wokeness she says is the only real
spiritual path of meaning available to
white folks that is how they View
wokeness by which they mean
a particularly virulent form of leftist
politics
and that is true
it's not literally true but that that
perception is
is accurate to them that's that's how
they are perceiving this thing
this is why the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence have to be allowed to mock
Christianity at Dodger Stadium
because the libs have foreclosed the
possibility that
Christianity is a path of spiritual
meaning that God is a path of spiritual
meaning that a relationship with our
maker and our savior
will give us spiritual meaning that is
foreclosed to them
or the concept of original sin they have
rejected that they don't believe that
they do recognize that sin and death
pervade the world which are the
consequences of original sin so how do
they make sense of that
the way that they try to make sense of
that is by saying that this is not a
consequence of original sin but it's a
consequence of institutional sin that
over the years
man-made traditions and institutions
have built up and they have oppressed
people and they've kept people down now
a logical question for this in response
would be okay well how did those
institutions and practices and
traditions get corrupted in the first
place they don't answer that part but
there are many people who believe it
there are many people who even say that
they're on the right there are some
people who even say that they're
Christian who are very
anti-institutional very anti-tradition
very anti-ritual they they partake to
some degree of the same
skepticism of and frankly disdain for
tradition
Institution
history
the the weight of practice the the
Democracy of the Dead that has been
built up our whole culture our whole
civilization and so for the libs in
despair they say okay I don't God isn't
real
Christianity isn't true I probably don't
even have a soul nothing seems to have
meaning at all and so the only way that
I can
I can impose some sort of meaning on my
life is through what is most
uh perceptible to me which is my flesh
my skin color there that by by
orienting my entire moral view around
just flesh and just literally the color
of my meat of My Flesh
that will give me some kind of spiritual
meaning
obviously it is not going to work
but that's how they view it
that's why they've got to allow the
sisters of Perpetual Indulgence to
jiggle around the stadium
they believe that the sis the real
sisters the real religious sisters the
carmelites the the the nuns
that they are the threat because what
they represent is a restriction on
individual autonomy
which is evil which is it comes from the
devil that's that that's the sin the
institutional sin we've got to fight
back against
and so this the sacrilegious character
of the sister of Perpetual indulgences
performance that's that's not a bug of
their troop that's a feature that's the
whole point that's why they have to be
exalted at Dodger Stadium
because the alternative would be okay we
we boot out these weird jiggling
and we we allow the religious
nuns to come in and I don't know say a
prayer or benediction before the the
baseball game
but then to do that
would be to say okay well
Christianity is true traditional
religion is true and this woke false
religion that's false and we're going to
suppress that from the Public Square
because that way lies Madness that way
Lies True oppression spiritual
oppression that way lies Decay and
decadence and degradation you gotta pick
one you can't you can't simultaneously
have them
both I'm glad you like that clip now
need you to subscribe ring that Bell get
all the notifications for the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel see you next
time